- This is it.
- Don't you die on me.
Don't count on it.
If this whole thing ended,
and there were only two pilots
left up in the air,
it'd be me, and it'd be you, Buck.
Today, the 8th will be sending up
three task forces.
That's the largest air alma mater
ever assembled
- in the history of mankind.
- (men cheering)
Masters of the Air is about
a group of American airmen
who did what was asked of them.
It's gonna to get bumpy.
Hang on, guys.
Despite the chances,
they were either gonna get killed,
wounded or captured.
I had thought it would be
easy to be in the sky
Rosenthal: Pilot to crew, flak ahead!
There's dangers
that you don't really think about.
There's more chance of you dying up there
than if you were down in the trenches.
These daylight missions are suicide.
In the face of unimaginable mayhem…
Egan: Fighters, 12 o'clock!
Nate Mann: …you have ten guys…
Egan: Open fire!
Let 'em have it!
Nate Mann: …in a machine,
trying to keep it in the air.
Any advice?
Try to stay alive.
Yes, sir.
When you're in combat,
you know who you're fighting for?
The guy to your left
and the guy to your right.
They have nothing but each other,
and they are able to conquer
anything when they stay together.
(Men laughing and cheering)
Egan: Come on!
I'm pretty sure that
this is the biggest production
any of us have ever done.
Gary Goetzman: Definitely the hardest.
Mission accomplished, boys.
This has been my dream,
to do something like this.
Let alone, with the team that made
Band of Brothers and The Pacific.
Woohoo!
Austin Butler: And getting
to bring life to these heroic men,
realizing how dangerous it was,
and the bravery with which
they fought our freedom.
That's the privilege for me,
and I hope that that's
what an audience receives.
♪
(mortar firing)
(plane buzzing)
(explosions)
♪